Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu u k w unsere kleine welt und wie sich ja hier schon abgezeichnet hat haben wir jetzt hier ein dauerthema nämlich die corona krise.
Und jeder versucht jetzt auf seine art irgendetwas in die öffentlichkeit zu schieben was vielleicht hilfreich sein kann und ja heute schiebe ich dann gleich nochmal ein,
weiteren beitrag nach nachdem ich mich in der letzten folge,
der sophie vom zerrt unterhalten habe um deren informationssendung und aber auch so ein bisschen ihre denkweise beim veröffentlichen von informationen.
Vorzustellen begrüße ich heute den bastian hallo sebastian.
Ja habe ich meinen namen schon gesagt mein name ist tim und ja sebastian du stell dich doch mal kurz vor was dich jetzt beruft mit mir zu sprechen.
Ja ich habe vor vor längerer zeit.
Angefangen aus dem zerrt heraus mich um das thema hygiene rund um die ganzen kongresse zu kümmern vor ort kann man mich vielleicht unter dem namen c drei gelb.
Wir haben uns hauptsächlich im küchenbereich,
da aufgehalten und vielen weiteren sachen dann auch immer wieder mitbekommen wo es bei der hygiene vielleicht ein bisschen drückt wo man etwas tun kann und was ich,
immer wieder in den ganzen darstellung der öffentlichkeit gesehen habe ist an es wird viel gesagt dass man hände waschen soll dass das ganz wichtig ist uns zu vielen anderen themen gibt's aber immer mit dem hinweis halte doch die allgemeinen regeln der der hygiene ein,
und.
Ich bin aber schon immer wieder menschen gefragt worden was heißt denn das eigentlich und was muss man da konkret machen und vielleicht können wir da ein bisschen licht ins dunkel bringen und so ein paar praktische handfeste anweisungen und und hilfestellungen zusammenstellen die.
Umgang mit der situation hoffentlich ein bisschen mehr handlungsfähigkeit für einen selber geben wo man selber ein bisschen anpacken kann und kleinigkeiten im leben ändern kann um,
damit dazu beizutragen selber nicht zu erkranken oder es auch eben nicht weiterzutragen.
Genau darum soll es heute gehen achso bist bist du da so ein bisschen so hammermäßig zu dem thema gekommen oder bist du auf eine andere art und weise auch beruflich mit dem thema verbunden.
Ja quasi dreierlei studiert habe ich an die partner medizintechnik und da war hygiene auch immer ganz großes thema,
da geht es nicht zuletzt auch darum dass man rausfindet wo sind stellen wo besonders viele keime sitzen wie kriegt man bestimmte sachen,
sauber und ja am rande des praktikums durften wir dann auch beim bernhard nocht institut hier in hamburg mal mit reinschauen und haben,
dort eine führung bekommen und auch einige praktische experimente dazu gemacht mit abstrichen und geguckt was bebrütet wie sich diese,
ja wie sich keime dann vermehren welche keime sind unabhängig davon habe ich bin ich schon seit über.
Fünfzehn jahren beim technischen hilfswerk aktiv und der bereich küche gehört da eben zum bereich logistik und dazu und da bereich logistik ist so mein steckenpferd dort und ja darüber habe ich rund um den bereich.
Küche und hygiene auch einiges an fortbildungen besuchen können und nicht nur wissen daraus an kameraden hier im einsatz weitergeben können.
Sondern auch zusätzlich noch an die auslands kameraden wenn man jemand im auslandseinsatz mitten in einem erdbeben gebiet war sowieso schon alles eher angespannt ist,
dann auch noch einen einfachen durchfall nur bekommt dann belastet das,
die mitgebrachte camping toilette natürlich über gebühr das gilt es zu verhindern und deswegen ist da ganz besondere sorgfalt angebracht und das gilt natürlich auch für.
Für alle engel auf dem kongress wo wir auf keinen fall wollen dass die,
was den irgendwas passieren kann und ja so wird überall an stellen wo man besonders auffällig sein muss eben auch besonders genau darauf geachtet dass da nichts passieren kann.
Das heißt mit dem du bist dann auch schon mehrfach nämlich an mit dem thw entsprechend ausgerückt hast du dann auch an solchen auslandseinsätzen teilgenommen.
Ja bisher war ich im irak und in kolumbien und tatsächlich hat es im irak genau mich mal erwischt da habe ich dann auch wassertank da war mit einem festen gebäude mit fließend wasser da habe ich auch mal einen tag zugebracht wir haben.
Sind eingeladen worden von kollegen die schon schon länger da sind und wir waren uns recht sicher dass das restaurant wo wir wo wir hingehen dort auch.
Ausreichend sauber arbeitet möglicherweise habe ich da dann im falschen moment zugegriffen so ein frischer salat zum beispiel ist etwas wo man dann nicht zugreifen sollte und.
Es gab dann glaube ich ein kleines missverständnis zwischen unseren einladenden und und uns und da.
Da auch der kollege der mit war recht betroffen die anderen waren schon ein paar tage da die waren vielleicht ein bisschen abgehärtet und da war das dann kein problem.
Aber aus fehlern lernt man.
Ja genau also
es wird jetzt schon klar du bist praktika und hast aber einfach viel mit hygiene zu tun und dementsprechend ist natürlich die aktuelle situation für dich auch so ein deja-vu der besonderen art nämlich an.
Ja klar also die diese virus weitergabe die im moment stattfindet darauf,
bereitet man sich ja im im hintergrund immer schon so ein bisschen vor weil man sich überlegt wo
könnte was passieren und jetzt ist was passiert und jetzt kommen natürlich die ganzen konzepte aus der aus der schublade paar davon funktionieren guten paar davon sind eben von der situation im moment überrannt und.
Die da kommen dann diese diese schnellen einfachen rezepte wie zum beispiel diese empfehlung für die mischt man desinfektionsmittel.
An ganz gelegen und ja so gucken wir jetzt mal dass wir durch die situation durchkommen.
Ich denke vielen leuten ist auch immer nicht so ganz klar diese einfache unterscheidung zwischen,
bakterien
und viren ja beides ist irgendwie klein und unsichtbar beides kann irgendwie krank machen vorbei wie fühlt man sich irgendwie so ein bisschen schutzlos oder weiß zumindest nicht so richtig welcher schutz wann wo greift da gibt's ja glaube ich auch ein paar klassische verwechsle vielleicht kannst du ja noch mal so kurz aus deiner,
das mal aufräumen.
Was man eigentlich generell erstmal verstanden haben sollte um auch alle anderen handlungsanweisungen richtig einzusortieren.
Ja grundsätzlich bakterien sind viel größer.
Und sind auch stärker alleine in der lage was zu tun so ein virus das muss immer erst in die wirtszelle rein und ist um einiges kleiner,
und hat eine ganz andere verbreitung antibiotika,
wirken gegen bakterien gegen viren eher nicht so und da unterscheiden sie sich im wesentlichen und.
In den fragen rund um die hygiene ist der unterschied wiederum gar nicht so groß denn da gilt es muss entweder weggewaschen werden,
oder eben mit desinfektionsmittel abgetötet werden damit es auf unseren menschlichen körper keine negativen einfluss mehr hat.
Aber wirken denn alle desinfektionsmittel auf dieselbe art und weise auf bakterien und auf viren.
In diesem fall für den korona virus im moment muss man sagen ja.
Denn alle desinfektionsmittel die so für hände und schnell desinfektionsmittel für oberflächen verfügbar sind die basieren auf zwei verschiedenen alkohol sorten.
Und diese alkohol mischung die zerstören die schutzschicht des virus außen ein sogenanntes gefülltes virus.
Und deswegen kann man mit allen verfügbaren desinfektionsmitteln zurzeit arbeiten das ist ein ganz großer vorteil,
wäre das jetzt ein ungewolltes virus sie sind mich wesentlich schwieriger kaputt zu machen dann würden wir eine sehr spezielle desinfektionsmittel mischung gebrauchen die,
viro zieht ist also die besonders gut gegen viren wirkt und die sind im moment noch stärker vergriffen als normales desinfektionsmittel ohnehin schon.
Und sind auch viel anstrengender für die haut das robert-koch-institut hat er drei verschiedene kategorien.
Vorgegeben es gibt begrenzt viro zieht es wirkt also gegen bakterien und einige viren begrenzt plus sonne.
Mittel schiene und dann gibt es virus präparate davon gibt es aber gar nicht so viel auswahl am markt weil die eben die hände so viel mehr angreifen und sie im normalfall auch nicht notwendig sind.
Auf auf was für viren sind die dann angelegt also was was sind das für für hüllenlos.
Und unabhängig von von von hüllenlos wir können einfach mal gucken die wenn so noro virus zum beispiel was ja für durchfall oder brechdurchfall sorgt.
Das braucht in vielen fällen schon an begrenzt wie routines präparat das heißt da muss man schon auswählen was für eine begrenzte zeit plus präparat da muss man also schon mal gucken was für eine bedrohungslage hier erwarten wir und was müssen wir,
nutzen um dagegen vorgehen zu können.
Und das ist aber jetzt derzeit nicht erforderlich der corona virus ist insofern einen von seiner basis struktur her ähnlich wie die normalen erkältungsviren richtig.
Naja besteht außen rum es ist corona ist ja die bezeichnung für krone weil er so stacheln quasi rundum hat und da hat man kann sich das als fett vorstellen er hat quasi diese kette außenrum der ist also wie wie so ein,
wie so ein hühneraugen auf der suppe schwimmt so kann man das sehr bildlich jetzt dargestellt und.
Das schöne ist wir kriegen halt diese kette dieses fett außen das kriegen wir mit spüli mit seife oder eben auch mit desinfektionsmittel kaputt gemacht und der ist sehr sehr empfindlich der virus das bedeutet auch eine relativ kurze einwirkzeit,
sorgt schon dafür dass er kaputt geht es gibt tuberkulose zum beispiel ist ein sehr sehr aggressives virus und da braucht man wesentlich mehr,
einwirkzeit und muss die hände möglicherweise zweimal nacheinander sauber machen damit wir das entsprechend bewirken kann.
Kurze zeit also ich hab jetzt gehört zwanzig sekunden sei so das was man als angemessen ansehen kann ist das das was du mal.
Es gibt die die standardzeit sind immer dreißig sekunden für die hände desinfektion und wichtig ist dass die hände währenddessen auch feucht bleiben von dem desinfektionsmittel ganz viele menschen nehmen sondern ganz
bisschen an desinfektionsmittel ist auch teuer und verreiben das auf der hand innenseite dann sind schon mal die kontaktfläche damit benetzt.
Aber um das sinnvoll zu machen wir fassen uns ja auch mal mit der rückseite der hand ins gesicht ist es natürlich sinnvoll die hände von allen seiten,
mit dem desinfektionsmittel zu benetzen und auch ein bisschen feucht zu halten für diese dreißig sekunden und dafür muss man ungefähr so viel nehmen wir in die handfläche passt,
die leute wollen dann auch schnell fertig werden wählen mit den händen hin und her dann verdunstet es viel schneller aber das ist ja ein chemischer prozess der da arbeitet und da muss auch genug zeit gegeben werden dass dieses,
dieser alkohol auf der haut dann wirken kann.
Jetzt müssen wir zwei sachen trennen also ich meine die desinfektionsmittel.
Die bearbeiten auf alkoholbasis gehen aber trotzdem gegen diese lipid ketten auch vor.
Während seife ja kein alkohol enthält sondern einfach als seife gegen diese diese fette die das ja letzten endes sind vorgeht und sind die beiden beide gleich gut oder wie.
Ja die sind schon sehr sehr gut weil unsere haut jeder kennt das man hat manchmal raue haut unsere haut erneuert sich ja ständig neu die hat schuppen drauf,
und in dem moment wo wir die schuppen von der haut abreiben beim waschen weil wir eben die hände mit ein bisschen reibung zueinander bewegen,
und waschen wir die schuppen weg in dem moment wo seife dazu nehmen,
können wir eben auch große mengen dieses virus ist dadurch kaputt machen und ihnen gleichzeitig wegwaschen das heißt selbst händewaschen ohne seife reduziert die keimbelastung auf der hand,
für alle keime jetzt nicht nur für korona sondern generell und immer.
Der unterschied ist nur wenn man die hände nur kurz unter wasser hält und dann sofort wieder abtrocknet dann bleibt die meisten sachen im handtuch hängen weil das handtuch das einzige ist was mit reibung,
und auch zeit mit der hand in verbindung kommt und deswegen ist es so wichtig dass man eben die zeit über dem waschbecken unterm wasserhahn und eben auch mit seife nutzt,
um
Ja quasi auch die oberste hautschicht also die stellen wo sich darunter alle möglichen keime eben drunter verstecken und festhalten können auch die möglichst zu entfernen und deswegen ist beim händewaschen reibung und druck was ganz wichtiges,
was den reinigungsprozess enorm verbessert und deswegen sollten im moment handtücher vielleicht ein bisschen häufiger getauscht werden als sonst.
Und das heißt auch dass man die stellen wo die hand auch viele falten hat also so an den finger,
gelenken etcetera und natürlich auch an den finger nahe übergäng und so weiter also solche ecken nochmal besonders bearbeitet.
Genau also die die anleitung die in letzter zeit überall rum gegangen sind auch auf twitter wir haben unter dem twitter-account,
von von drei gelb gelb auf twitter haben wir auch ein bild mit uv-licht gemacht.
Von händen die bewusst nicht gut gereinigt worden sind und das sind aber so die ganz typischen stellen wo man sehen kann die man die man gerne auslässt und wenn man sich auf der nächsten veranstaltung sieht wenn also physisches zusammenkommen wieder möglich ist wir,
haben normalerweise die uv-lampen und das zubehör dafür mit dann könnt ihr das natürlich gerne bei uns ausprobieren und mal schauen welche stellen hier erwischt oder welche eben auch nicht.
Also uv-lampen aber jetzt nicht dass man mit der lampe den virus sieht sondern indem man vorher das ganze mit einem mittel macht was dann entsprechend floristik hat und man sieht dann durchs uv-licht wo man nicht abgewaschen hat.
Genau also da haben wir.
Das ist so ganz typisch in der krankenhaushygiene auch als selbstlerner effekt für alle mitarbeiter dass man dann desinfektionsmittel nimmt und das mit florian u v farbe versetzt,
und dann hinterher gucken kann welche bereiche bei der desinfektion die man halt täglich dutzende hunderte male machen muss welche stellen man dabei nicht vernünftig erwischt,
um da selber dann nochmal ein bisschen besser zu werden.
Wenn man jetzt die wahl hat so ein alkohol desinfektionsmittel zum händewaschen zu benutzen oder seife was würdest du denn in dem moment bevorzugen.
Wenn ich die auswahl habe nehme ich meistens seife.
Und und wasser weil es wäscht die keime weg desinfektionsmittel macht die keime nur tot aber sie sind da noch da und deswegen ist die hände waschen in aller regel hygienischer.
Das infektionsbad eine gute lösung für unterwegs oder wenn es wieder medizinischen personal der fall ist schnell von raum zu raum geht eben auch schneller weil man nicht die zeit am waschbecken stehen bleiben muss,
aber gerade jetzt mit der quarantäne zu hause um oder im im alltag ist für die meisten fälle das waschbecken die wesentlich bessere wahl und das favorisiere ich auch weil es ein besseres frisches hautgefühl gibt.
Was war ja nun auch am laufenden meter hört ist so dieses bitte nicht das gesicht berühren das fällt manchen leuten leichter anderen nicht so sehr,
ich habe ich habe da so für mich selber abgeleitet dass wenn ich sozusagen ohnehin schon viel zeit auf hände waschen verbringe ich dann einfach mal mein gesicht auch wasche.
Das ist sicherlich auch zu empfehlen oder.
Ja grundsätzlich schadet das nicht also solange die hände sauber sind kann man sich ja ins gesicht fassen also direkt nach dem desinfizieren direkt nach dem waschen ist das überhaupt kein kein problem es wird in dem moment eine schwierigkeit wo man jemand anderem die hand gereicht hat wo,
im moment ja auch ganz stark darauf verzichtet wird und ja klar natürlich auch werden sollte
aber in dem moment wo man keime an der hand hat und sich dann ins gesicht fest er bringt man
mehr oder weniger von diesem virus ist direkt ins gesicht und wir wissen im moment von dem korona virus das er besonders dann oder so wird es zumindest vermutet,
besonders dann effektiv arbeiten kann wenn er bis in die atemwege kommt also wenn man einatmet während jemand anderes hustet und wenn man,
das statt durch diesen husten strom eben mit seinem finger macht indem man halt.
An der hand viele keime hat und die dann bis in den mund rachenbereich bringt wenn man sich.
Ins gesicht oder an die lippen sogar fast und dann später wieder über die lippen drüber legt was man ja auch ganz häufig tut.
Ohne darüber nachzudenken genau dann kann man damit die krankheit natürlich gut unterstützen und das.
Kann man ganz gut vermeiden wenn man sich nicht ins gesicht fast zumindest nicht zumindest nur direkt nachdem man sich die hände gewaschen hat.
Gut.
Was hast du denn so selber jetzt über den virus gelernt aus dem was bisher alles veröffentlicht
wurde was jetzt speziell auch für die hygienemaßnahmen die man jetzt für sich treffen sollte relevant sind.
Ja das wichtigste was was man immer guckt ist wie lange kann ein virus überleben und genau an der stelle,
ist im moment noch keine klare zeit die im raum steht es stehen also gibt informationen dazu dass bei bei flugzeugen und herausgefunden haben will dass es zweiundsiebzig stunden auf kunststoff.
Überleben kann auf kupfer soll es ganz besonders kurz gehen deswegen in notaufnahmen jetzt geguckt wird ob man einige handgriffe einige türgriffe ersetzen kann durch kupfer.
Da guckt mal was man machen kann aber das was,
bekannt zu sein scheint es es werden pro zeit immer weniger viren insbesondere wenn die viren keine nährlösung haben in der sie schwimmen also wenn wenn es ganz trocken ist das heißt trockenheit tötet den keim,
und zeit und das können wir uns natürlich im häuslichen umfeld und im büro umfeld zu nutze machen weil es eben keine neuen tage sind wie es zu anfang im raum stand sondern jetzt ein langes wochenende das ist natürlich deutlich deutlich besser,
und es heißt ja auch nicht dass dieser virus ab dem ersten einzelnen virus der den körper,
besiedeln möchte zum problem wird sondern man ist sich auch dessen bewusst dass eine gewisse menge an viren notwendig ist deswegen wird ja von der,
bundesregierung gesagt wenn man fünfzehn minuten mit jemandem spricht dann steigt die wahrscheinlichkeit eben drastisch an und.
Die dieses virus kann dann deutlich wahrscheinlicher auf jemand neues übergehen.
Also.
Das glaube ich auch relativ wichtig meine wir haben es noch nicht getan wir tun's jetzt einfach mal trotzdem auch wenn es jeder schon fünfzig mal gehört hat aber dieser doch wirklich hochinteressante
podcast mit dem trosten im büro logen hier von der charité der führt ein jahr zunehmenden maße und gerade in den letzten tagen wie ich finde ganz toll auch immer mehr auf die wissenschaftliche ebene mal jenseits der allgemeinen warnung und politischen debatten die er ja eigentlich so gar nicht viel
führen möchte.
Da kam das glaube ich auch auf und er hat auch nochmal darauf hingewiesen so okay also wenn jetzt eine studie sagt das ding ist drei tage auf der oberfläche dann heißt das nur.
Man kann das wissenschaftlich im labor nachweisen dass da noch welche da sind.
Nur nimmt halt die menge auch extrem schnell ab so dass das jetzt nicht unbedingt bedeuten muss dass wenn jetzt eine fläche
vor drei tagen mal kontaminiert wurde dass man mit kontakt,
mit dieser fläche automatisch auch eine nennenswerte menge virus aufnimmt aber genau wissen tun wir es jetzt auch noch nicht das sind alles nur
dinge die wir sind im prozess viele studien und untersuchungen laufen derzeit mal macht beobachtung und kann natürlich auch jederzeit nochmal irgendeine andere information wieder ans tageslicht kommen wo man sagt so aha ok darüber war so noch gar nicht nachgedacht oder unter diesen bedingungen ist es dann doch nochmal anders als bisher vermutet.
Genau und da wird im moment geforscht die die ersten,
ergebnisse kann man wirklich aus kalifornien drüben und da wird halt nicht nur nach oberflächen geguckt sondern ja die menge ist halt entscheidende wieviel aufgetragen wurde und wie,
wie lange die nährlösung auch noch reicht für für das virus und ja trockenheit könnte uns da tatsächlich einen riesen vorteil bringen.
Was würdest du denn aber trotzdem raten inwiefern man quasi jetzt die hygiene auch so über den eigenen körper hinaus und die eigenen handy hinaus
auch noch weiterführen sollte insbesondere im haushalt wo sind maßnahmen angemessen und wo es rainer putz fimmel.
Überall da wo es wo der virus feuchtigkeit hat und wo viele leute anfassen also mit einem vernünftigen also mit einem normalen haushaltsreiniger gerade so den wasserhahn nochmal.
Abzuwischen das tut uns auch alle nicht weh das ist eine eine sehr geringe maßnahme.
Bevor man etwas nicht durch erhitzt ist was man später in den mund bringen wird anfässt da die hände zu waschen und eben auch nachdem man dinge angefasst hat die draußen waren oder die jemand anders in der hand hatte.
Ansonsten würde ich so viel mehr gar nicht machen die,
frage ist halt ob man dinge die man vor längerer zeit schon besorgt hat ob man die jetzt so anfassen kann ich mache mir wenig sorgen wenn ich die käse packung aufmache ich.
Leg dir halt die die die am ältesten packungen halt nach hinten und die.
Jüngster die die die jüngste nach hinten die ältesten nach vorne und damit hat der virus ja auch eine gewisse zeit gehabt sich da schon mal wieder zu beruhigen und hoffentlich,
die kleine menge die von davon dass irgendwer irgendwo mal irgendwas angefasst hat mich dann hoffentlich nicht mehr ereilt.
Wenn man das mit dem das mit dem wasserhahn ist ein ganz guter hinweis ne weil wenn man sich jetzt mal denkt so okay alles klar jetzt bin ich ja so zum öffentlichen wasch
ort so was machen die leute als erstes okay sie nehmen vielleicht irgendwie seife aber dann machen sie irgendwie den wasserhahn an das heißt bevor sie sich gewaschen haben.
Sind die finger dreckig klar.
Fassen sie sozusagen diesen diesen hahn,
an drehknopf was auch immer knauf et cetera dann wäscht man sich die hände,
dann ist das die ganze seife abgespült und dann dreht man das wasser nochmal ab aber halt quasi nur mit feuchten händen sprich,
dort kann kann der virus ja eigentlich wunderbar auch lange bleiben weil der knopf sagt nauf potenziell immer wieder befeuchtet wird,
ja aber eigentlich nicht abgewaschen wird.
Genau das ist zum einen natürlich ungünstig zum anderen,
früher wurde immer beigebracht ja dann drehe den wasserhahn zum schluss mit dem handtuch zu dass du zum abtrocknen verwendet hast die,
so ein papier handtuch das durchfeuchtet natürlich sofort und die schutzwirkung davon die ist sehr sehr gering also das was man da versucht hat.
Glaube nicht dass das allzu viel bringt,
dementsprechend ist da das sauber machen gerade auch im im häuslichen umfeld oder in der firma nicht das verkehrteste aber auch hier man kann natürlich ein weniger benutzten bereich der hand nehmen man kann wenn es ein wasserhahn ist mit einem hebel daran kann man natürlich auch mit der rückseite der hand,
wieder zumachen oder vielleicht auch mit dem ellenbogen oder dem unterarm und all das sorgt dafür dass man,
den wasserhahn beim zumachen dann nicht mehr anfassen muss und mit der unterseite des unterarms fest man sich relativ selten ins gesicht.
Ich hab's mir jetzt einfach angewöhnt erstmal die seife zu nehmen und dann mit mit der seifige hand sozusagen den wasserhahn zu bedienen wenn's nicht anders geht
weil dann habe ich dem zumindest schon mal noch eine kleine seifen spülung noch zusätzlich mit verpasst und im besten fall damit auch gleich nochmal desinfiziert.
Genau wenn das jeder machen würde dass das wäre klasse wenn also jeder den den wasserhahn nochmal waschen würde während der während nachdem er ihn benutzt,
das würde natürlich einiges bringen aber das blöde ist ja wir wissen ja immer nie wo der virus ist dementsprechend sind alle vorsorgemaßnahmen das,
stellt da draußen ja auch wieder raus wer es glory prevention.
Und ja alle vorkehrungen die man jetzt so trifft die sind natürlich gut dass man versucht diese diese diesen diesen virus einzudämmen und auch sonst dort mehr auf sauberkeit zu achten aber,
ganz nachweisen wo er sich wie genau verbreitet ist halt schon auch arg schwierig.
Wurde den kühlschrank erwähnt hast wenn ich das richtig sehe gibt es noch keine gesicherten erkenntnisse darüber wie gut oder wie schlecht sich der virus mit hohen oder niedrigen temperaturen so hält.
Der hohe temperaturen zubereitung von lebensmitteln da habe ich bisher nichts gehört dass sich jemand irgendwie über zubereitete lebensmittel,
die erhitzt worden sind angesteckt hat also da würde ich im moment von ausgehen gerade auch wegen den ketten dass das auf jeden fall sicher ist also nahrungsmittel sind bisher nicht im fokus,
zumindest keine die verpackt weitergegeben werden weil die ja meist auch länger als ein paar stunden liegen da es mir bisher nicht bekannt dass das auch nur ansatzweise ein problem darstellen würde.
Bei einem frischen salat naja mit seife waschen will man den nicht aber die je kürzer vor dem verzehr man ihn abwäscht und wenn man die äußeren blätter entfernt sehe ich da auch wenig schwierigkeiten also das bisher nicht drüber bekannt dass das,
das lebensmittel selber ein problem wird bei den verpackungen dann schon eher.
Heißt was also dass man.
Ich würde mal so ein beispiel einkaufen zum beispiel nehmen wenn man unterwegs ist im im supermarkt sind ja auch andere leute.
Und die müssen husten na klar wie du dich wenn wir den supermarkt gehen und es dann in dem moment passiert dass man hustet dann kann es halt sein dass kleine tröpfchen,
die vielleicht auch kaum sichtbar sind außen auf der packung sind und wenn man jetzt nun die packung mit nach hause nimmt dann kann es sein dass man eine gar nicht so geringe menge,
von virus mit nach hause trägt das weiß man aber nicht weil er kann ja vor einer halben stunde rausgepustet haben.
Deswegen passt ich vom einkaufen so ein bisschen auf dass ich gucke dass ich mir da nicht so viel mit nach hause nehme.
Viruslast sage ich mal.
Ja und worauf achtest du dann.
Ich nehme mir lupe und gucken ganz genau hin viel spaß beiseite.
Der herr mit dem mikroskop.
Bitte an kasse fünf ja.
Nee ich nehme ganz normal weil in meinem rucksack mit meine meine baumwollbeutel zum einkaufen also damals alles wie sonst aber vor dem supermarkt mache ich mein handy lautlos und steckt in die tasche und ich hole es erst wieder raus,
wenn ich mir danach erneut die finger gewaschen habe weil wenn ich irgendwas anfasse und damit die viren aufs handy bringe das handy ist eine unheimliche also smartphones im besonderen ist natürlich überall dabei,
und ihr auch immer am gesicht oder in der nähe und unsere finger auf dem display das ist ein ganz großer,
eine ganz große möglichkeit wie man ja viren überall durchbekommt weil wir das gerät halt immer bei uns tragen es ist schön warm,
und eben nach einem langen telefonat am gesicht auch definitiv bei einigen leuten recht feucht und.
Da passe ich ein bisschen auf dass ich das in der tasche lasse.
Und ja wenn ich dann eingekauft habe alles verpackt hab und den einkaufswagen viele sagen ja auch einen einkaufswagen oh mein gott was da alles drin ist die müssen desinfiziert werden dann müssen sie vor jeder benutzung desinfiziert werden und das überall und das.
Ist ja faktisch nicht leistbar.
Und na ja wenn ich dann einkaufen fertig bin alles verpackt habe wieder rausgehe und den einkaufswagen weggestellt habe also beim wegstellen des des einkaufswagens.
Da desinfiziere ich mir dann die hände und dann kann ich wieder aufs handy gucken ja oder ich lasse es einfach mal die zehn minuten bis zu hause in der tasche.
Und wenn ich dann durch die tür komme wasche ich mir die hände bevor ich mir jacke und schuhe ausziehen.
Und packt dann aus die älteste die jüngsten sachen nach hinten also first in first out fifo wie das in der logistik.
So schön heißt schau dass da möglichst alles so ein bisschen schräg steht damit überall luft zwischen kommt,
damit es halt trocknen kann auch im kühlschrank so gut es denn möglich ist und dann wasche ich mir nochmal einmal die die finger und habe dann ja aber nichts mehr an mir was ich getragen habe draußen als ich bei den beim einkaufen war was gegen den einkaufswagen gekommen sein könnte,
die packung die stehen dann ja auch erstmal mehrere stunden oder im idealfall sogar ein zwei tage bevor ich sie wieder in die hand nehme und ich für mich.
Ich glaube dass das in den meisten fällen ausreicht um.
Etwas etwas zeit zu geben es verbessert die lage auf jeden fall und ja menschen die jetzt ganz ganz vorsichtig sein sollen zudem gehöre ich jetzt nicht,
die könnten so eine packung nochmal abwaschen aber ich der virus wird viel stärker durch das persönliche übergeben und deswegen ist das was ich da mache einfach nur,
einmal oder zweimal mehr hände waschen je nachdem wie häufig man das sonst machen würde und eben das handy mal eine zeit lang weglassen und ich persönlich verspreche mir davon schon dass sich meine persönliche chance nicht zu erkranken etwas erhöht.
Das funktioniert bei mir überhaupt nicht weil ich ja irgendwie ohne einkaufsliste auf dem telefon vollkommen aufgeschmissen bin.
Ich habe diese zettel wieder entdeckt die sind total klasse die kann man dann hinterher auch einfach wegtun und ich komme da ganz gut mit klar.
Oh gott was mit bargeld.
Ja auch bargeld auf bargeld lebt gerne was sich jedes mal danach die finger zu waschen ist ein bisschen anstrengend und schwierig aber,
das portemonnaie und die finger das.
Wenn man man man virus übernimmt von jemandem an ist da auch was dran deswegen wird ja im moment versucht um den abstand zwischen kassiererin kunden zu erhöhen immer mit diesem schüsselchen zu arbeiten.
Das reduziert nicht die die keime auf dem bargeld aber es reduziert die berührung von kassierer und kunde und.
Das ist halt grundsätzlich gut weil auch da wieder nachdem was wir bisher wissen und das ist leider noch nicht so viel nachdem auch so bisher wissen ist trockenheit eben schon gut für.
Fürs abtöten des virus.
Ja es ist noch nicht so lange her da musste man sich schräg angucken lassen wenn man kontaktlos bezahlen wollte jetzt sind die leute eigentlich ganz glücklich wenn man's macht.
Ja total karte reinstecken dass halt das eine karte auflegen ist dann natürlich die die bessere wahl,
und ja so ein das eingeben des bin kurz wenn es mehrere nacheinander machen ist es halt auch wieder eine berührung na also berührungslos ich weiß nicht bis welchen betrag ist das mit mit nur karte auflegen.
Das hängt glaub ich so ein bisschen von der bank ab ob man da eine pin eingeben muss das sind aber meistens die niedrigen beträge aber wenn man halt also ich meine ich bin.
Wenn du jetzt fünf packungen.
Apple watch ja ich bin mit einer apple watch unterwegs da kann ich da bin ich biometrische identifiziert da kann ich halt auch irgendwie tausend euro mit bezahlen also das ist nicht so das ding also bei man hat.
Ja also weil man da sozusagen schon authentifiziere ist wenn man die am arm hat das eigentlich die die beste lösung gilt auch halt
das telefon aber es muss halt wieder rausnehmen aber die uhr ist eigentlich optimal ich zahle eigentlich sowieso alles nur noch mit der uhr
zumindest in supermärkten also nicht erst seit korona sondern einfach weil es generell hilfreich ist und ja das ist glaube ich in dieser situation,
ganz hilfreich aber man muss jetzt auch glaube ich nicht so eine mega panik machen wegen viren auf bargeld oder.
Sie können halt ein bisschen was übertragen aber auch da haben wir,
man spricht ja immer früher hat man von der schmier infektion gesprochen das ist versucht man immer zu vermeiden die vokabel des jahres hier heißt kontakt kontamination oder kontakt infektion,
wir haben immer in dem moment wo wir etwas anfassen hinterlassen wir kleine mengen von dem was wir an den händen haben darauf.
Und man hat mal experimente gemacht mit floristik in der farbe wo also hinterher das halbe haus und große teile des gesichts dann bunt waren.
Das schöne ist ja dass es immer nur ein kleines bisschen was ist was da drauf ist aber es kann eben reichen insbesondere wenn wir hier sind wenn wir uns hinterher ins gesicht fassen also.
Betrachte bargeld schon als möglichkeit wie der virus eben auch von personen zu personen kommen kann,
und ich habe mein portemonnaie ich habe keine handtasche mit out ich mich jetzt mal,
und dadurch hat es mein portemonnaie in der hosentasche manchmal dann auch warm und wenn man irgendwie noch zum bus gelaufen ist dann auch mal feucht warm und das ist natürlich keine besonders feindliche atmosphäre für den für den virus.
Okay also alle apple watch kaufen.
Absolute option.
Du hast auch irgendwelche hinweise zum einkaufsprozesse.
Ach ich glaube im moment können wir uns nicht beklagen die supermärkte sind ja mit vielen sachen noch voll,
und wenn wir uns da ein bisschen da können wir im moment noch richtig richtig angenehm.
Kochen das einzige wie gesagt was ich mache dass ich gucke ob ich da beim auspacken ein bisschen vorsichtiger sein kann als sonst und im supermarkt selber natürlich.
Aber sonst denke ich mal kommen wir doch noch ganz gut durch die aktuelle situation möglichst selten einkaufen gehen könnt und noch eine option sein weil.
Hallo.
Einkaufen geht dann hat man natürlich weniger chancen sich mit seinen mitmenschen draußen zu treffen und dann noch weniger schon sich anzustecken es ist eine relativ einfache rechnung.
Ja es ist gar nicht so einfach man muss ja jetzt eigentlich jeden tag den supermarkt laufen und gucken ob schon wieder klopapier da ist.
Ja das ist die neue wertpapier anlage habe ich gehört ich weiß gar nicht wo ich.
Ja aber nicht sonderlich verfügbar also von daher das ist sozusagen das also solange man noch klopapier hattest
ja ganz gut aufgestellt manchmal meine ich müsste es jetzt auch langsamer so weit sein aber offensichtlich haben die leute so viel schiss.
Dass sie das dass sie das mit klopapier abdecken müssen.
Hast du ja auch eine dusche oder eine badewanne dich bei uns dann kann man ja auch mal das was in der arabischen welt recht verbreitet ist die reinigung mit wasser vollziehen und sich da einfach mal auf andere kulturen einlassen das ist ja auch.
Problemlos machbar aber muss ja nicht gleich zu der kanne.
Im irak ganz speziell für mich die haben dort wie man es aus frankreich vielleicht wohnt ist diese französischen hockt und die haben dann eine kanne wie eine gießkanne wie man zum blumengießen kennen so zwei drei liter groß und.
Wird die türe ein bisschen dicker und dann wieder dünner damit man also damit sich damit man den wasserstrahl richtig an die stelle lenken kann wo man ihn braucht und.
Muss gestehen ich war sehr froh um die im rucksack verstaut tolle rolle klopapier denn an einem öffentlichen restaurant mit einer gemeinschaft kanne,
zu behelfen das war für mich dann schon ein kulturschock,
wo ich nicht richtig vor sozialisiert war in dem moment wo ich unterwegs war da war ich dann froh dass ich mich schon vorbereitet hatte und.
Diesen ausflug dann mich nicht ohne toilettenpapier überstehen musste.
Jetzt ist ja ganz interessantes fallen einem jahr jetzt sozusagen alle momente auf wo man überhaupt noch kontakt mit der außenwelt hat wenn man erstmal so ein bisschen weg isoliert ist.
Und ja die person die man jetzt am häufigsten sieht sind eigentlich paketdienste.
Die möglichkeit sich was zu bestellen ist natürlich auch mal ganz klasse,
aber weil die paketdienste im moment noch beschäftigt da sind halt sonst ist natürlich die chance auch groß dass man dann von nachbarn oder vom nachbarn drei häuser weiter,
noch ein ja schönen gruß mitgebracht bekommt der hat er reagiert und hat,
gesagt die paketboten dürfen jetzt selber unterschreiben und müssen ihr gerät gar nicht mehr aus der hand geben aber direkt neben der türen und stift aufzubewahren die man dann natürlich nicht anmacht um das display zu zerkratzen sondern,
auslässt um damit zu unterschreiben dann spart man sich zumindest schon das entgegennehmen des des stifters und ansonsten kann man sich ja auch überlegen wenn man da bedenken hat,
dass man das paket einfach vor der eigenen tür öffnet.
Und sich dann zwischendurch einmal die die finger wäscht oder einen freund freundin wer auch immer mit dem man gemeinsam wohnt dann den inhalt des pakets rausnimmt und,
damit hat man glaube ich zumindest wenn man diese zeitkomponente wenn die denn,
so schlimm wie die aktuellen studien sagen ganz gut genutzt weil der inhalt des paketes der ist ja vierundzwanzig stunden oder je nach paket versender auch drei wochen vorher aufgegeben worden,
und müsste deswegen relativ sicher gestorben sein außer man hat jetzt reagenzien und,
nährlösung bestellt dann haben wir natürlich ganz andere probleme aber grundsätzlich wenn man sich jetzt also wie du schon sagtest die,
neue watch bestellt hat dann sollte die eigentlich kein frei oder zumindest von diesem virus unbelastet,
im paket liegen und damit kann man natürlich die die viruslast dann vor der tür lassen,
und äh ja ich habe so einen so einen cuttermesser mir neben die buttermesser und einen stift.
Neben die tür gelegt das heißt ich mache das dann im zweifelsfall draußen auf und entweder schütte ich es aus das funktioniert immer ganz gut also umschütten.
Oder ich nehme das dann mit gewaschen händen raus wie gesagt wenn ich.
Nicht ohnehin das paket schon erst aus der packstation hole.
Hoffentlich schon ein bisschen gelegen und dann möchte ich vielleicht die umverpackung beim einladen ins auto schon entsorgen dann gebe ich einfach den gegenstand ins ins auto und versuche dann in der nähe.
In dem papier container einfach den karton schon entsorgen dann habe ich das problem gleich gleich ganz gelöst für mich.
Oder das paket erstmal vierzehn tage in quarantäne die besenkammer.
Könnte man auch versucht aber die meisten sachen möchte man ja gerade jetzt haben wenn man ohnehin im home-office ist das fehlende kabel nachbestellt hat oder so da muss man ja auch gucken dass man das was man da reinkommt ich glaube die zeit hat man nicht immer.
Jetzt haben wir viele bei desinfektionsmittel geredet aber es gibt ja keine kriegt man ja noch noch schlechter als klopapier.
Außer in der langen schlange von aldi neulich das war ja vor einer woche oder anderthalb da hatte aldi schon aus früheren zeiten desinfektionsmittel noch bestellt es kam dann in die läden die haben dann auch sofort die die abgabe mengen reduziert.
Und gesagt nur noch zwei oder drei flaschen pro ich glaube popo kunde und also das war binnen von rekordzeiten war das überall ausverkauft.
Und das ganz lustig zu sehen die leute die haben also in den schlangen dich gedrängt angestanden für desinfektionsmittel um sich gegen,
eine kontakte infektion zu schützen das war,
schon so ein bisschen in sich eine schräge nummer und ja meine hoffnung ist dass ich mit mit diesen worten auch bisschen was transportieren kann von es ist nicht alles grausam draußen wir können rausgehen wir können uns draußen auch bewegen,
nur ja die leute die im park jetzt zusammen gesessen haben dass es,
ist halt blöd und ja zum desinfektionsmittel es gibt keine mehr viele von uns haben ja auch zum zum basteln aufkleber entfernen oder sonstiges,
teile von desinfektionsmittel zuhause und wollen jetzt diesen diesen hinweis befolgen mensch mischt ihr dann desinfektionsmittel doch selber.
Für für seine einzelanfertigungen zu hause da gibt's dann auf einer,
war auch von sophie zerrt mit drin die die world health organisation die weltgesundheitsorganisation die hat,
da auch in zwei rezepte verbreitet für unterschiedliche alkohol sorten also für ethanol und physioplus alkohol man braucht dann auch noch.
Wasserstoffperoxid und glizerin wird so hin wird als als hautpflege dann verwendet aber das ganz große firmen geheimnis von den ganzen desinfektionsmittel herstellern ist ein wirklich gutes hautpflege konzept,
zu machen das sind wir zu uns mittel selber gibt es ganz viele aber ich habe auch das letzte mal bei der blutspende war die rufen ja im moment auch auf dass sie wenig,
spender bei sich begrüßen dürfen habe ich gefragt mensch was ist denn eigentlich euer liebstes desinfektionsmittel die haben wechseln an andauernd weil die klinik ausschreibt,
und die sagten naja die unterscheiden sich schon ganz enorm darin gutes den händen hinterher geht die benutzen das natürlich auch ganz häufig am tag,
das heißt für unsere anwendung wenn wir jetzt nur den paketboten hallo sagen wollen
und den pizza lieferanten ist das nicht so wild da kann man diese rezepte sicherlich nehmen aber ich würde erwarten dass das im krankenhaus umfeld dann zu problemen führt und die wichtigste barriere an den händen die wir dagegen haben sind nicht die handschuhe sondern sehr gut gepflegte haut also,
wenn man anfängt zu merken dass die hände sprühe werden ruhig eine vernünftige creme dahaben und benutzen,
denn wenn die haut anfängt einzureißen dann schützt sie uns halt nicht mehr das ist es mir ganz wichtig die die hautpflege die.
Ist jetzt wichtiger denn je und lange fingernägel und ähnliches die werden dann natürlich auch immer wieder zum problem wenn man da nicht runterkommt,
dann kann man das nicht sauber machen und es ist glaube ich auch eine gute maßnahme die einige altenheime jetzt getroffen haben dass sie gesagt haben,
also viele besucher können wir jetzt nicht mehr.
Also das mit dem trockenen händen ist mir jetzt auch schon aufgefallen das problem hat man im winter ja je nachdem wie die eigene haut so angelegt ist ohnehin schon mehr oder weniger manche so manche so
die viele wassereis scheint bei mir dann auch so einige hautreizungen ausgelöst zu haben.
Der ich jetzt erstmal so mit panthenol ganz gut entgegen arbeiten konnte
wie es scheint also bepanthen so ist ja so eine ganz klassische haut wiederherstellung mittel also panthenol ist wenn ich das richtig sehe auch so ein stoff der quasi.
Besonders pflegend.
Die haut sozusagen zur wiederherstellung auch anregt.
Also das scheint zu helfen aber generell ist sozusagen auch feuchtigkeitscreme et cetera alles zu empfehlen aus seiner perspektive.
Ja ja das auch da gibt es wieder die spezialisten die sich da schon lange mit beschäftigt haben aus raumfahrt und forschung.
Nein also raumfahrt jetzt nicht unbedingt aber aus der forschung aus dem alltag heraus wenn man so eine flasche oder so eine tube benutzt dann fest man ja wieder ein gegenstand an und wenn man den nicht alleine benutzt oder wenn man den mehrfach am fest
kann der natürlich auch immer wieder eine übertragung verursachen und deswegen ist es sinnvoll dass man das entweder frei runterfallen lässt.
Oder wenn man das abstreift dass man das auf die rückseite der hand macht weil im idealfall greift man ja alle dinge die man anfässt mit der vorderseite der hat.
Und mit der hand innenfläche.
Und deswegen sagen die creme techniken dass man vom handrücken aus anfängt und handrücken anhand rücken verreibt weil der handrücken in der regel weniger belastet.
Sein müsste und wenn man beim waschen vielleicht doch was übersehen oder vergessen hat verteilt man dann nicht so viele keime,
in richtung also von der handfläche auf den handrücken sondern wenn man mit der creme halt in der umgekehrten reihenfolge arbeitet also von der außenseite der hand zur handinnenfläche dann kann man glück haben dass es ein bisschen weniger keime sind und gerade wenn man.
Trockene hände hat und die handcreme einfach so anwendet verhindert man damit ein bisschen besser als sonst.
Dass man in die tube selber was rüberbringt ich habe gerade noch mit einer,
pharmazie bekannten telefoniert und die war so ja ja die tuben die sind ein riesenproblem diese ganzen kunststoff tuben die sind ja im prinzip nichts anderes als die pipette komisch geguckt aber klar hat er recht in dem moment wo so eine kunststoff tube gedrückt wird,
kommt der creme raus und indem wir sie loslässt ist wie eine pipette saugt es das wieder rein und das sie hat geschwärmt von den alten blech tuben.
Weil da war das problem zumindest nicht der fall und ja trinkwasserbereich wissen wir immer eine freifall strecke einhalten das ist.
Ja vor vor ein zwei jahren wurde die vorschrift für trinkwasser verändert und das ist seitdem die ganz große vokabel in dem bereich.
Freifall stecke freifall strecke.
Ja auch die feuerwehr musste ihre hydranten umbauen damit man auf jeden fall sicherstellt ist auf gar keinen fall irgendwas ins trinkwassernetz zurückkommen kann.
Und das kann man entweder durch eine freifall strecke von ich glaube es war das zwanzig dreißig zentimetern gewährleisten.
Oder eben durch zwei rückschlag klappen das heißt jedes feuerwehrauto die hydranten die sind jetzt alle umgerüstet worden und haben rückschlag klappen dazu bekommen damit auf gar keinen fall.
Wasser von so einem.
Von außen eingesungen werden interessant.
Und das kann man natürlich bei der creme jetzt eins zu eins nutzen und auch bei allen möglichen sachen also.
Irgendwas woanders reinkippen oder frei fallen lassen ist natürlich immer sicherer als es anzufassen weil wir es hier mit einer tröpfchen und kontakt.
Infektion zu tun haben und je weniger kontakt wir haben umso besser ist das.
Überall gefahren.
Es ist schlimm ja ja.
Ich sehe das auch total mit einem lachenden und einem weinenden auge weil natürlich ist es jetzt für für mein thema hygiene voranzubringen eine ganz.
Auf eine tolle zeit sagen ohne das jetzt also das ist mit einem lachenden und einem weinenden auge jetzt merkt man halt dass es gut war vorkehrungen zu treffen jetzt merkt man halt dass es
gut was ich an an verschiedenen stellen darauf vorzubereiten daran zu forschen und gleichzeitig tut es vielen menschen wie ich schaue mich gerade auf dieser worte weil man möchte natürlich nicht dass es irgendwie schlecht geht dabei,
aber es ist unheimlich faszinierend wie also so ein klitzekleines.
Mit mit einer einseitigen erna so mit einem strang nur im inneren geschützt von ja quasi so ein bisschen fett wenn man das so,
einfach ausdrücken will also von diesen streng wie das unseren körper in die knie zwingen kann und.
Unheimlich interessant wie wie wie auch das ganze thema mit dem mit dem testen und eben auch mit dem nachvollziehen der wegstrecken vorangeht dass da auch ein riesen.
Diesen thema an dem geforscht wird im moment.
Welche tipps können wir denn jetzt noch den leuten mit auf den weg geben was kannst du jetzt noch so raten abgesehen von dem was wir jetzt schon besprochen haben.
Wer die die drei a regel abstand abstand abstand ist die die im moment natürlich in allen kreisen gepredigt.
Die natürlich auch der.
Der verzicht auf auf unnötige besuche aber das sind so die sachen die im wesentlichen aus den den medien kommen die wichtigsten sachen,
sind die bereiche wo wir kontakt zueinander haben und da wird überall schon darauf geachtet dass man nicht mehr jeden schreibtisch besetzt oder eben auch büros,
schließt dass man die darauf achtet dass man eben sachen sauber macht wenn man sie teilt oder eben auch persönlich zugewiesene,
dinge verwendet und diese diese desk sharing arbeitsplatz oder so die sind im moment hoffentlich dann auch persönlich zugewiesen und nicht mehr.
Für alle zum teil gedacht.
Coworking ja ja okay das ist auch nochmal ein problem ich wollte jetzt eigentlich gar nicht so sehr auf allgemeine verhaltensweisen hinaus sei jetzt sozusagen nochmal so konkret hygiene
vielleicht auch in der eigenen wohnung weil da spielt sich ja sozusagen derzeit das leben auch im wesentlichen ab.
Ja absolut in dem moment wo man.
Verhindern mit einer mit einer anderen bekannten aus im groß küchenbereich telefoniert die sind im moment natürlich auch,
ganz stark auf diese sogenannte schwarz-weiß trennung aus das handy feuerwehrleute vielleicht von chemie unfällen und in der küche macht man das eigentlich auch da gab's schon immer den weg von,
von der kalten küche also der der der vorbereitung von speisen dann rein in die in die richtige große küche wo dann,
gekocht wird und das ist genau die richtige stelle so hat man zuhause jetzt nicht unbedingt mehrere räume dafür aber die arbeitsvorbereitung ist da glaube ich ein ganz ganz großes,
thema geht so ein bisschen in die gleiche richtung wie bei,
einkauf und und auch paket sich den kopf drum machen was fasse ich nacheinander an und was davon ist sauber und was davon ist nicht so sauber und wenn wir jetzt diese zwei vokabel schwarz und weiß,
einfach mal dafür benutzen wenn ich auf die saubere also weiße küchenoberfläche.
Sauberen oben und unten frisch aus dem geschirrspüler oder schrank sauberen weißen heller stelle dann ist erstmal alles sauber.
Kann ich den mülleimer vielleicht vorher nochmal aufmachen und kann dann zum beispiel,
eine packung käse nehmen kann den inhalt kann es öffnen und dann sind meine hände ja schwarz weil die packung könnte von außen ja schmutzig sein.
Wenn man das dann fallen lässt auf den teller oder in die tupperbox oder was man dafür dann verwenden möchte dann kann ich damit eine eine packung die vorher potenziell,
schmutzig war in den mülleimer werfen mir die finger waschen dann sind die wieder sauber und dann habe ich das gesamte,
sauber in die küche gebracht und das einfach nur weil ich mir den kopf drum gemacht habe in welcher reihenfolge ich das tue und mir dann einmal die hände gewaschen habe dass es dann vielleicht wichtig wenn man zuhause,
menschen hat die besonders empfindlich sind die vorerkrankungen haben für die meisten anderen fälle glaube ich kommt man ohne aus aber wir haben immer wieder menschen,
aus aus meiner erinnerung die dann auch beim zerrt zum beispiel vorstellig werden,
selber von sich wissen dass sie bereits erkrankungen vorerkrankungen haben und die nun besonders vorsichtig sein wollen und für die kann ich mir das als als guten tipp vorstellen,
ich kann aus meiner kindheit zumindest noch diese mehr etage tupperbox wo wir unseren aufschnitt immer drin hatten und ja bei mir erlebt die gerade in der renaissance.
Einfach um dinge besser wegzulassen gern und zu zeigen sauber zu halten.
Genau der küchen ausbildung ist halt auch mal also wir nennen es im kongress umfeld frikadellen diplom,
das ist also die die belehrung für für groß und gruppen küchen und da ist immer wichtig dass man alle sachen von denen was abtropfen könnte zum beispiel dass man die in den unteren bereichen des kühlschrankes lagert also wir haben eigentlich,
temperatur im kühlschrank ist immer so ein so ein thema in den.
Wo man was in den kühlschrank liegt aber eben unter kontamination gesichtspunkten auch ob irgendwas darunter tropfen kann und ich habe alle packungen jetzt unten in der schublade alle geschlossene.
Und die sachen die ich dann schon irgendwie sauber gemacht habe im oberen bereich und so trenne ich die möglicherweise nicht ganz sauberen sachen oder halt schwarz dreckigen sachen von den sachen die ich.
Ja schon mal irgendwie sauber gemacht habe und natürlich baue ich selber auch immer darauf dass mit der zeit,
virus ja auch austrocknen und absterben muss.
Schwarz und weiß einfach immer im hinterkopf behalten schwarzes alles was irgendwie potenziell dreckig sein könnte und wenn man so auch drauf schaut dann dann sieht man's den dingen wahrscheinlich auch das erste mal so richtig an.
Ja als ich direkt nach den nach den praktika rund um jene wo wir dann,
geguckt haben was was auch so ein rettungswagen schmutzig ist die werden ja auch einmal die woche grundgereinigt da wird alles rausgenommen alle schubladen auf alle taschen raus alle.
Instrumente einmal abgewischt der boden sehr feucht mit entsprechender desinfektionslösung gewischt alle oberflächen alle wände,
das ist eine unheimliche aufwand und da haben wir mit diesen plättchen so nährlösung plättchen haben wir abstriche gemacht vor und nach der reinigung und es ist dramatisch viel weniger,
aber man kriegt nicht alles weg also wir müssen uns immer von dem gedanken trennen dass wir hundert prozent erreichen können das geht in dem bereich gar nicht.
Aber es ist immer wieder interessant was wo noch überlebt welche stellen wir mal vergisst und,
das war eine sache die im moment auch immer wieder gesagt wird die menge an virus die,
der körper wahrscheinlich ab kann die unterscheidet sich natürlich von personen zu besuchen aber es gibt ganz häufig den fall dass ein bisschen virus eben noch nicht krank macht sondern erst ab einer gewissen menge die man zugeführt bekommt,
und sobald wir unter diese menge kommen ist es zwar nicht sauber aber sauber genug.
Das heißt auch wenn wir jetzt hier wieder identifiziert eine lange liste aufgemacht haben mit wo überall das böse virus lauern kann
das ist jetzt auch nicht so dass es überall lauert so und gerade in der aktuellen saß zwei wie rost situation.
Volvo corona virus geht's eigentlich im wesentlichen erstmal darum
sich von menschen fernzuhalten weil das ist nun mal der ort wo übertragen wird und es gibt ja noch keine wirkliche klarheit darüber wie lange jemand auch wirklich,
infektiös ist aber wenn ich das richtig sehe geht man derzeit so von knapp einer woche aus
so wo es sozusagen überhaupt zu einer infektion kommen kann und dass das trennen der menschenmassen hier einfach schon eine ganze menge bringen wird.
Davon ist auf jeden fall stark auszugehen.
Ja sebastian hast du noch irgendwie was so sonst noch rüberbringen möchtest was wir jetzt vielleicht noch nicht aufgezählt haben als guter hinweis oder so.
Ja zwei sachen fallen mir gerade noch ein das eine ist es haben sich verschiedene pfleger zu wort gemeldet die ich gelesen habe und das klingt jetzt nicht ganz unlogisch was sie sagen sie sagen wenn man denn erkrankt dann bleibt.
Bleibt ein bisschen mobil wenn ihr könnt legt euch nicht hin sondern bleibt aufrecht und es scheint mir sinnvoll unser körper ist ja dafür gebaut zu stehen,
zu laufen und wenn wir jetzt hinlegen sind in der lage die gar nicht so sinnvoll ist und ich würde dann natürlich nochmal ein arzt zu befragen wollen das habe ich noch nicht geschafft,
aber wir erscheint es logisch dass man im zuge einer erkrankung der lunge sagt mensch trinkt genug bleib möglichst aufrecht dann hast du eine gute chance dass du.
Den den teil der lungenentzündung auch entsprechend auspusten kannst und du brauchst genug flüssigkeit im körper um das eben auch ab husten zu können das sind scheint mir sehr logisch,
da dürfen natürlich die mediziner nochmal zu wort kommen aber das klingt für mich in sich schlüssig.
Ja also generell ist ja auch so dieses rausgehen und an die frische luft kommen und sich irgendwie vielleicht auch mit sport
fit zu halten durchaus sinnvoll wenn man jetzt sich einer bedrohung gegenüber sieht die einen ja potenziell an die luft und an die leistungen und an die widerstandsfähigkeit will und wenn man halt da diese widerstandsfähigkeit durch bewegung und eben im idealfall vielleicht auch sport
aufrecht erhalten kann oder vielleicht sogar auch gewissen maße noch ausbauen kann dann kann das ja im zweifelsfall ganz gut sein.
Und ansonsten das was was es überall gibt dass jetzt der atmosphäre selber gebaut werden wollen finde ich,
unheimlich spannend unheimlich interessant hatten wir im rahmen des studiums natürlich auch das was da passiert ist ein unheimlich komplexes gefüge aus dem zeit volumen beim beatmen also wenn es in den patienten,
geht die luft und natürlich auch,
das ausströmen wieder zwischendurch müssen brücke ganz genau gehalten werden es geht darum wenige millibar um wirklich die lunge nachzuempfinden und.
Dann die die beimischung von von sauerstoff die möglichkeit co zwei zu entziehen oder raumluft zu verwenden.
Allein die befürchtung also wenn unsere lunge austrocknet das ist ein ganz großes problem in der beatmung und da drücke ich auf jeden fall den leuten die sich dann im moment beschäftigen ganz doll die daumen dass es ein hochkomplexes thema und,
das ist super spannend da erfahrung zu sammeln gerade wenn das geräte werden können.
Wie gesagt guck ich mit größter neugier drauf die dann.
Auch ja einen patienten längere zeit unterstützen können denn das ist ja in italien moment ein riesenthema das das.
Zu wenig behandlungsplätze vorhanden sind und da drücke ich die daumen dass wir diesen wettlauf.
Dass wir in diesem wettlauf vielleicht ein bisschen vor den virus kommen können.
Super sebastian vielen dank das waren viele ganz praktische tipps und ich glaube das ist auch das was wir derzeit so ein bisschen ganz gut gebrauchen können.
Ja das war's hier bei ukw mit dieser ausgabe beim versuch hier
nützliche informationen in die welt zu bringen wenn ihr anmerkungen habt rein in die kommentare damit wenn ihr noch vorschläge habt was man sich auch nochmal genauer anschauen und anhören sollte dann nehme ich das auch gerne auf.
Ja und ansonsten sage ich bis dahin erstmal tschüss und bis bald.